so Bard has been updated with Gemini Pro
functionality I believe whatever that
means so now they have Google Deep Mind
yes Google bard and Google Gemini yes
well what the what's going on here with
The Branding Google tell me what I'm
tell me explain to the audience the
difference between those three things
just so we can level sit here okay well
Deep Mind and brain were two independent
teams inside of Google that have been
merged into a single team that's now
called Deep Mind Deep Mind Deep Mind is
the remaining brand that's their AI team
that's their AI team now and that's like
saying that's equivalent of saying open
AI it's equivalent of saying open AI yes
correct and historically those two teams
had different approaches and they came
from different worlds Deep Mind was an
acquisition that Google did uh years ago
that actually led to some of the Fallout
between um Elon Musk and some of the
Google Founders yep and um you know some
of the key folks that were involved in
the drama with open a ey this week Ilia
in particular was a deep mind person
that was recruited out to come to open
the ey so it's very kind of some
important details those two teams now
have created a new model a multimodal
model we've started talking about these
we've used them and that model is called
Gemini and Gemini comes in three
different versions and those three
different versions basically are um
different size parameters which have
different capabilities and pro which is
the middle siiz model is now available
for use inside of Bard and on an API
level it's going to become available on
Wednesday so if you're working with
Google Cloud you you can use it uh as an
API like so the same way you can build
things on top of open Ai and chat GPT
and gpts um and then Ultra which is the
kind of the most advanced model they
said will be available in early
2024 okay help yes we have the Deep Mind
team that's the group inside of Google
the consumer product is called Bard Bard
now Bard is a way for them to say hey
this isn't Google search this is a
different experimental product it's
going to hallucinate click here to
understand you shouldn't like base your
medical decisions or financial decisions
based on Bard Bard's an experiment then
Bard uses an underlying technology
called Gemini Gemini Gemini comes in
three flavors Nano Pro Ultra Ultra yes
so we now have one two three four five
six Brands this is a message to Sundar
we've talked about this you and I okay
branding at Google is challenging it's
challeng you call it Google bard a much
better idea would have been to take the
YouTube approach and just call it bard
and get the domain named bard.com and
let people go to bard.com and have a
completely unique verticalized
experience without the Google branding
yeah and then nobody needs to know about
Deep Mind nobody needs to know about
Gemini it's just Bard yeah and Bard is a
new product from Google yeah the end
well Microsoft nailed this too with the
naming co-pilot which you know um we had
a little private chat where we were
sharing some names and ideas and we said
co-pilot the way to go it's the simplest
and nobody can own that so Google
co-pilot would have been a better name
yeah um for this they just call it co-
pilot but you know what Google's
strength is in the underlying technology
their weakness is in branding and often
in ux and the the problem I have with
Bard right now is there's no app right
there's no Google bard app and the
interface is just I don't want to say
it's terrible but it's like the I'd say
the UI is like a five of 10
and I feel like chat jpt is is like an
8.5 yeah well no can I say one thing to
not to Google's defense but like very
similar in branding and naming we have
open AI we have chat GPT and we have GPT
3.5 G GP GPT 4 GPT 4 so they've kind of
taken the same flavor consumers but they
didn't have a legacy brand of Google
right so there is no Legacy so there
they can they can start from a little
bit of a cleaner position people know
chat GPT they don't really know open AI
they really don't care about the version
numbers you just search for chat GPT
this is why Google you should just
search for Bard and then all they should
say is Bard let you do this you can use
Bard for this you can use Bard for that
and then yeah when you go to the dev day
they can talk about all the underpinings
but the consumer should just experience
Bard and Bard should have a logo and it
should be bar.com this is why Google
plus failed I don't know why Google
keeps doing the same mistake which is
putting things as like a subtopic under
the word Google YouTube is your biggest
success it is an independent strong
brand with its own domain name goog plus
got lost because it was plus.google.com
it should have just been called plus.com
and you went to plus.com and you had
that
experience yeah fascinating so here end
The Branding lesson you have to get this
right Google please better name than
Bard to CU like no one knows what a Bard
is I mean yes I agree I mean they should
have just bought chat.com I would have
just bought chat.com and you know who
bought it Dar mesh I think bought it for
a million dollars over at HubSpot yes um
and the huge mistake wow what a oh my
God a I mean for Google that's like one
millisecond of sear imagine if they just
had chat.com and it' be like hey yeah if
you want to chat go there or AI chat.com
or ai.com yeah you know it's just
there's so many different ways to do
this folks but yeah the way Google does
it is always a mistake there's no
branding person there and nest had a
great branding team and then you screwed
it by having the Google team shoehorn it
into and break it into Google home there
should be a five alarm fire actually you
know what this is a Sergey thing Sergey
find somebody who you trust who's your
Johnny I I heard Sergey is in there
writing the code right yeah Sergey needs
a Johnny he one that pushed for the
release apparently oh really let's go
yeah
yeah I like Sergey after do he's Ser I
like I likeon millionaire writing code
we have chamat and we have Sergey I love
it Samurai Sergey he's worth a 100
billion he's writing code I so much
respect Samurai surge Serge oh I like
Samurai Sur he's in the game oh yeah but
this is a message somebody send this
message to Samurai Sergey I I know him
jakal okay Samurai Sergey please hire
your Johnny ey find a branding person
and stop taking Google's Innovations and
wrapping them in bad ux this is a place
to invest like literally just find 10
great designers put them in a room don't
let anybody near him I think Johnny Hive
has Johnny Hive has a studio now he
could just acquire
it yes go get I mean go give Johnny I a
billion dollars and and have him come in
for 10 hours a week he'll do a better
job than the Google team no offense to
the Google team yeah they're doing a
bunch of work for like Silicon Valley
companies like a little bit Studio yeah
Design Studio buy them if your landing
page looks terrible I'm out we all know
that you see an ugly website you
scadaddle you leave you're done so you
need to stop sellling for okay or good
and start using Squarespace so you can
be excellent and extraordinary it's an
outof the-box Business Solution to build
beautiful websites engage your audience
and sell anything you want you know
Squarespace is amazing features gorgeous
templates that are always optimized for
mobile drag and drop web design with
their fluid engine Advanced analytics
marketing analysis sales data and more
and with Squarespace you can create an
online store or start a blog at the
click of a button create a subscription
business for membersonly content and so
much more and you can do this All
simultaneously it's the simplest most
effective and best looking way to start
a business online so here's your call to
action squarespace.com twist for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com twist for 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain